regardless of where you're from each
country assigned certain qualities to
certain animals the wise owl the brave
bear and more relevant to today's video
the crafty and intelligent Fox the
Japanese word for Fox is of course
kitsune which has been a long requested
video and finally the patrons have
decided that it will be this week's
video of choice when I use the term
kitsune it's likely many of you will
think of a nine tailed fox but in
Japanese folklore all foxes depicted as
been very intelligent beings with the
power to transform and shape-shift into
a human in ancient Japan the foxes were
closely linked to in early the Shinto
deity of fertility rice and agriculture
due to their association of Inari
foxes and humans live closely together
no one really knows why the foxes were
in our days animal of choice but because
of this the stories of the kitsune arose
as a way to explain the animal
supernatural significance the kitsune
was someone of whom expect in some tales
there were the friends and faithful
guardians of humans even stretching as
far as the lovers and wives of Sun then
Nura tales of the kids who know where
they are cunning tricksters using their
power to trick humans and even sometimes
other kids in a if the idea of
nine-tailed Fox's is one that is often
associated with the kitsune but not all
of them had nine tails in fact the more
tails their kids in they had the older
wiser and more powerful they were
thought to be so we can assume that
grown additional talents is something
that may have happened over time those
that did possess nine tails were
considered to have the same power as a
Shinto God and so many people would make
sacrifices to them as if they were a
regular deity the most common number of
tails of the kids may appear to have is
one five seven and nine when a kitsune
does eventually gain its ninth tail its
fur becomes white or gold and they
gained tremendous sight and hearing
being able to see in here almost
anything so how long does it take for
the kid's name to gain tail number nine
there are several accounts of this
process but the most common being that
after they become a thousand years old
the kids today then gains a ninth tail
it then becomes a golden celestial Fox
in a sense of the heavens now this
wouldn't be video about a Japanese yokai
without mentioning its origins and
Chinese mythology in Chinese folk tales
there are stories of Fox spirits called
hua Jing these foxes also had numerous
tails but the exact number isn't very
clear the kitsune as we know it today
seems to be an adaptation of Chinese
Indian and already exists in Japanese
influences though the idea of the Fox as
a seductress seems to be an idea unique
to Japan
between 1603 and 1867 the Edo period of
Japan there was a fair amount of
superstition surrounding foxes much like
all of the animals that were associated
as witches familiars such as black cats
Badgers and of course foxes
they were then labeled as a witch animal
these foxes were also called goblin
foxes and as you can imagine they were
not the friendly foxes that we discussed
earlier
goblin foxes were attributed with
strange occurrences in the household the
change in weather in the possession of
humans returned kitsune etske translates
to mean the state of being possessed by
a fox they would often choose young
women and they would enter from beneath
the fingernails while being possessed
sometimes the victims facial expressions
would change to resemble that of a fox
and they would have a sudden craving for
sweet things so how does one deal with
one of these Fox positions well
originally it was thought you could
force the Fox to leave its host by badly
beaten and burning the victim but as you
can imagine this wasn't the best idea
and it led to many individuals and
entire families being ostracized Arthur
family members thought to have been
possessed in the years that followed it
became common practice to perform an
exorcism at one of the shrines of Inari
one could assume that the presence of in
Lodi may have caused the Foxes to leave
out of respect or even fear as weird as
the Fox possessing someone may sound it
did have very real effects and the
Japanese property prices buying a
property from someone who owned the Fox
came of a negative stigma the
association of dangerous and dark
practices even when these prices were
slashed wires are still hard to come by
so we know that the kitsune are a type
of youkai but there were two common
types of kitsune li Zheng Qi which meant
the good foxes these are the benevolent
celestial foxes associated with deity
Inari they were also called the Inari
foxes the second kind where they are Co
whose name and filled foxes but they're
also commonly known as nogitsune these
Kitson a were mischievous and always
looking for trouble their intentions
were sometimes out of a trickster to
provoke and get a rise but at times they
were far more malicious although it's
stated that the kitsune can take the
form of a human it's not an ability
they're born with once they reach a
certain age which ranges anywhere
between 50 to 100 years old they then
learn how to become a human in medieval
Japan it was a common belief that foxes
would impersonate beautiful women if one
was to encounter a beautiful woman
especially alone in a dark it was most
commonly a kid Sanae up to no good the
only way to know for sure was to look
for a tail as the kids they were known
to have troubles concealing their tails
in human form
another way to identify kids may in
human form would be through their hatred
for dogs so if your girlfriend seems to
be particularly rattled by a puppy then
it's time to run she's definitely a
kitsune or maybe she's just allergic to
household pets either way I guess it's
best to refer back to method 1 and find
a tail I'm sure many of you are aware
that one of the kids and his many
supernatural abilities is to generate
lightning but they were also capable of
generating fire some of you I'm sure
will no the Pokemon nine tails and nine
tailed fox that was a fire-type Pokemon
yet another one of the many mythological
influences found throughout the
franchise the kids nose abilities are
honestly quite endless it's believed
that they could fly and turn invisible
whenever they needed to they could also
create extremely powerful illusions and
ability that any good trickster would
need the kids they could create these
illusions in person or in one stream
they often appeared so convincing that
individuals had problems distinguishing
between what was an illusion and what
was reality there are many tales of the
kitsune appearing at someone's door as a
woman in distress after they have been
taken in by the locals the next morning
they would find much of their food and
valuables had been stolen they would
often add insult to injury by cutting or
shaving the hair of those who had shown
them kindness so far most of this
behavior is in line of the tricks of
persona but as we've already mentioned
there were kids today whose intentions
were cruel and evil they would use their
illusions to lure victims to places
where they had caused them harm and
potentially kill them the tricks that
gets enabled preferably target greedy
merchants boastful commoners and overly
proud samurai people they essentially
believed had it coming the malicious
kids and they prefer to target poorer
villages and commonly Buddhist monks
with the majority of them being men
women of course would instead be
possessed there's a very particular game
that kids named joy to play with humans
they came across the game itself was
called Fox fist and there's a game very
similar to rock-paper-scissors the
symbols were replaced by hand positions
that signify a fox a hunter and a
village headman the village headman
beats the hunter because he outranks him
the hunter beats the Fox because he
shoots him and the Fox beats the village
headman because he bewitches him there
isn't much said as to what happens if
the human order kids never victorious so
we can assume that this game may have
been nothing more than a bit of harmless
fun I don't really know how to
coherently sum up the kid's name one
phrase or sentence so to me the kids nay
are a mixed bag they come in different
shapes sizes and colors some are good
some are mischievous and some of course
evil
tickets tonight almost feels like you're
flipping a coin you may end up getting
married to a fox tailed woman or you may
not be murdered by the exact same fox
old woman I'm sure all of you guys will
be posting animes and mangas that they
featuring that I've never heard of so
feel free to share any thoughts or
knowledge you have on the kids stay with
me in the comments below as always I've
been your host mythology and fiction
explained
you